must be
Rihanna I love you and I dressed up as
you for Halloween I just had to say that
if I believed in Halloween I would have
dressed up as Rihanna as well I'm gonna
say something very controversial Rihanna
you take all the time you want on that
album girl don't let these fools on the
internet pressure you into nothing
was Rihanna's first time at the globe
she was up for best original song facing
off against Lady Gaga and Taylor Swift
but all three were beaten by not to not
to from the movie rrr we're calling him
the pop diva Slayer what do you want to
say to them I wanted to say to them I'm
not your contender
I'm your family now so how'd Rihanna
react to the upset watch closely as she
points and congratulates the RR team
that's why she's a queen and a fashion
icon too
wearing that velvet's capparelli gown
and Cartier diamonds we chatted with
Angela Bassett took selfies and enjoyed
her date night out with ASAP Rocky
[Music]
and Gabbana custom baby
this is Chanel it's surprisingly
comfortable
that's all my son my dresser he said
Mama you look like the award I said all
right thank you baby just a little heavy
but it makes more noise you should hear
it I said oh y'all gonna see me today
yeah the Golden Globes returned and the
fashion was fierce as ever
it's heavy it's like a suit of armor I
mean I bet someone could punch me right
here and I wouldn't it would hurt them
more than me Jessica Chastain's sheer
spider web dress was ripped from the
runway another star wearing a heavy gown
Cheryl Lee Ralph no shade it's custom
made how about that my daughter Ivy who
is with me this evening styled me for
this weighing in around 20 pounds the
dress took 960 hours to make the Abbott
Elementary star actually rocked two of
the night's Trends heavy metals really
Hollywood tonight it is a silver number
and big trains and capes from Rihanna to
Selena and Viola Davis whose Jason blue
gown got soaked by the rain someone who
didn't have that problem Heidi Klum in a
sick when Minnie she ended the night
with a snack and herself some sausages
Jamie Lee Curtis gave us an off the rack
moment with this lace Cape it just made
me happy I saw it at Neiman's while
Billy Porter took part in another trend
of the night pink he presented producer
Ryan Murphy with a Lifetime Achievement
Award he asked me to wear the Oscar
dress and I said I don't repeat
and so I called Christian siriano and he
came up with this instead
we're loving those rhinestone platform
boots too Billy but tonight's best
accessory just might be baby bumps
Kaley Cuoco walked the carpet and custom
beer a wang and shared a kiss with
boyfriend Tom Pelfrey Claire Danes
already a mom of two showed off her
surprise this one was is not so expected
so but we're thrilled and here we go I'm
in the second trimester which is the
more forgiving chapter so I'm grateful
we're out of the nausea yes the mayor's
Abby Elliott Kennedy who's having a boy
went for orange sequins and first time
Mom to be Hilary Swank rocked Prada the
48 year old is expecting twins with
husband Phillip Schneider mama is here
and I'm only six months I have three
months to go okay you've got two of
those babies in there yes I do I love
being pregnant
um and I just feel so blessed and so
happy happier than I've ever felt
foreign